when you desire one thing over another
or you want to become one type of person
but not the other you may think that's
your personal
preference one psychological explanation
of human behavior argues that we often
have no idea what we want and hence just
imitate others welcome to mimetic
[Music]
Theory memetic theory is the idea that
there are really only two sides to Human
desire physical desires are our cravings
for utility the intrinsic value of
objects metaphysical desires are our
longing for identity what objects can
say about
us if you are hungry you may want to eat
anything to satisfy a physical need or
you might wish to eat out in which case
you may pick a place that reinforces
your self-conception your identity and
the person you wish to become in other
words you want to please your
metaphysical desire Renee Gerard the
French philosopher who established the
theory argued that most of our desires
are metaphysical and called them mime
because we mimic them from the people
around
us we imitate others because we long for
their recognition hoping that we will
eventually become a heightened being
that will be remembered ideally
forever however since this ideal is so
abstract and so to achieve we take
shortcuts and make associations with
objects and models whom we think have
already achieved this
status and so our deepest desires and
moral principles are fundamentally
anchored by models and the objects
values and culture associated with
them in school we want to wear what the
cool kids are wearing and by the same
logic we never ever want to look like
the social outcasts
this common longing for and against
certain models raises a fundamental
question do we in fact have any
autonomy if we simply want what others
want our decisions are not truly ours
and we are far from being independent in
our Behavior individualism is a
formidable lie Gerard wrote and this
leads to a
problem the relationship between a
subject and an object unfolds through a
model also called a mediator who desires
the same things eventually this can lead
to rivalry between subjects and
mediators especially if they start
imitating each
other and as both don't like the thought
that they cannot have what they want
they look for a victim who they can make
responsible as a result they unify their
imitative desires around the destruction
of an agreed upon scapegoat to the point
where that person is singled out
expelled or killed after the social
order is restored and people are happy
to have solved their problems the cycle
begins
again what do you think was Gerard right
and are we all trapped in societies that
tell us who we should want to become or
do we have our own independent desires
that go beyond our need for food and
shelter share your thoughts in the
comments
below
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on